Das ist wirklich ihre der friedhof der raumschiffe point nemo es ist der wohl
abgelegenste ort der erde überhaupt teilnehmen und zwischen chile und neuseeland und mehr als 2000 kilometer vom nächsten
Stückchen land entfernt und genau dort ist auch der friedhof der raumschiffe wie es dort aussieht und wie die
sterbenden raumschiffe genau beerdigt werden jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Weltraumschrott ist nicht nur müll sondern tatsächlich ein
unkalkulierbares risiko erst vor kurzem haben wir hier darüber berichtet dass teile der chinesischen raumstation tiangong
1 schon bald auf die erde stürzen werden denn die chinesen haben die
kontrolle über die station verloren und gehen jetzt davon aus dass tiangong 1 ende des jahres spätestens, im frühjahr 2018
Abstürzen wird ein großteil wird wurde in der atmosphäre verbrennen doch experten
experten warnen davor dass grosse trümmerteile von bis zu 100 kilogramm auf
Die erde treffen werden aber auch die unzähligen anderen trümmerteile die den weltraum mittlerweile regelrecht vermüllen
Stellen eine bedrohung für uns da das sagen forschungsteams weltweit die nasa warnt vor einer
unkontrollierbaren
kettenreaktion eine absolute katastrophe dass kessler syndrom
ausgelöst durch einen crash werden innerhalb von stunden
großteile der flugkörper rund um die erde zerstören inklusive der
internationalen raumstation iss immer wieder schlittern wir daran vorbei es gab bereits 200 kollisionen
Im orbit der erde und jede produziert wieder neue schrott teilchen zwischen geht man von
166 millionen trümmerteilen aus die um die erde schwören wir sind im moment quasi zeuge eines kessler syndroms in zeitlupe
spektakulärer höhepunkt 2009 stoßen der us-satellit nummer 33 des iridium
satellitentelefon netzes gewicht eine halbe tonne und der russische satellit cosmos 2251
zusammen bei einer aufprallgeschwindigkeit von
40.000 kilometern bleibt von beiden satelliten nichts mehr übrig außer rund 100000 schrott teilchen sie haben jetzt die
Chancen für den nächsten unfall deutlich erhöht damit das risiko für eine solche katastrophe sinkt werden ausgediente
raumschiffe satelliten und sonstige welt raumflugkörper
Beerdigt und zwar hier auf der erde dafür haben sich die weltweiten weltraumagenturen den isolierten punkt der welt ausgesucht point nemo
Eine stelle im südlichen pazifik rund
2600 kilometer vom hexen stück land entfernt konkret von dead island
einem teil der pid kern insel motor
einer neben insel der osterinseln und maria island was zur antarktis gehört und das ist wirklich ein riesiger
abstand wenn er euch vorstellt dass die raumstation iss in rund 400 kilometern
Höhe um die erde kreist deswegen ist point nemo übrigens auch als
pazifischer pohl der
Unzulänglichkeit bekannt etwa zwei wochen braucht man um dorthin mit dem schiff zu kommen und natürlich auch wieder zwei wochen um zurück
zu gelangen das risiko dass ein trümmerteil
auf land einschlägt dass gezielt support nemo gesteuert wurde ist also nahezu null die gefahr dass hier irgendjemand
Geschädigt wird ist absolut minimal obwohl ich könnte mir einen katastrophenfilm vorstellen bei dem zum beispiel ein atomgetriebenes
schiff von einer raumstation
Getroffen wird ja aber das ist dann doch doch wirklich wahrscheinlich ein bisschen zu viel fiction imo wurde übrigens mit hilfe eines computerprogramms
Entdeckt und zwar im jahr 1992 von dem kroatischen
vermessungstechniker
Luca täler den namen hat dieser ort allerdings nicht von dem fisch nemo aus dem zeichentrickfilm
Sondern eine romanfigur und zwar kino aus 20.000 meilen unter dem meer von jules verne an dieser stelle
Im ozean vermutet man nur sehr wenig leben denn der wind kann nur wenig nährstoffe hin tragen
Da das nächste stück land so weit entfernt liegt starke meeresströmung
halten nährstoffreiches wasser
zudem ab also wirklich
Der ideale ort um alles zu begraben was man nicht mehr braucht laut nasa ist dies vor allem für größere objekte wie
raumstationen und raum fahrzeuge die sich in einer niedrigen umlaufbahn befinden eine hervorragende möglichkeit denn bei ihnen besteht die gefahr dass sie eben nicht
vollständig verbrennen bevor sie den erdboden erreichen solche raumschiff und satelliten werden dann ganz kontrolliert zum point nemo
gebracht und dort dann zum absturz es gibt schätzungen nach denen hier sagt weshalb 71 mehr als
260 raumfahrzeuge
Beerdigt worden sind und die zahl ist in den letzten jahren gewaltig gestiegen unter anderem ist hier auch die mir die
122 tonnen schwere russische raumstationen begraben russische objekte sind übrigens deutlich in der überzahl wohl mehr als
200 objekte aus russland sind dabei und der friedhof ist alles andere als klein
unvorstellbare 17 millionen
Quadratkilometer soll der groß sein und auch die iss wird wohl demnächst an diesem ort für immer
Ihre letzte ruhestätte finden am point nemo schlummern also große teile der weltraumgeschichte am meeresboden eine wirklich beeindruckende
vorstellung in das ding vielleicht können wir diesen raumschiff friedhof ja mal
Besichtigen ja viele fragen ja immer mal wieder nach unserem equipment die links dazu
Habe ich in die video beschreibung gepackt wenn er noch
Fragen habt stellt sie mir in den kommentaren wenn ihr kein video zum thema, weltraumschrott und auch
Zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht den achtung
Genau auf die glocke denn nur dann verpasst er kein video wie zum beispiel dieses hier
Weltraumschrott das ende der raumfahrt droht mit noch mehr infos zum drohnen keppler syndrom absolut spannendes thema und ansonsten wie immer bis dann
bleibt dran